The jogan Experience yeah the crazy saw
bones are very interesting y so let's
talk about that because we've we've
showed photos on the podcast before um
and that these saw bones now you have
carbon dated them and they're to win
here they are yeah you're not going to
believe this cuz we got all excited when
we found them yeah plus or minus 200
years they're 190 years so what what
kind of animal are these from I don't
know
but they're 200 years old 190 here I
brought one with me oh really this is
uh the story about how these were found
is I got a call one day I was out there
at the Boneyard my daughters have a
tourist business around the corner a
little bit called gold daughters and Aur
called me up and goes dad there's a
State Trooper over here wanting to talk
to
you and I look around my truck to see
what I got in it
I said okay I'll be right over I go over
and we had some stuff going on at the
time
and I didn't think there was any reports
filed any place but I go over there and
introduce myself to this guy and it's
his name is Eric
Spitzer he's the head state trooper in
Fairbanks he says I was just out in the
neighborhood I I wanted to come by and
introduce myself I saw you on Joe
Rogan's podcast I love f
I love what this is all about is my kids
like to look for bones and I take them
out in the woods and we look for stuff
and I just wanted to come by and
introduce
myself and he the the excitement in his
just him T talking to me I said well
follow me over we'll go I'll go show it
to you right now so he went over to the
Boneyard he got out and he looked around
he just couldn't believe it he picked up
some bone Parts I said well now you're a
boner
you just got to find one and uh we
[__] a little bit he goes you mind
if I bring my kids out sometime I said
bring them out this weekend we'll fire
the pumps up I'll turn you guys loose
and then we'll come check on you once in
a while and they found a poor too full
of Bones little fragments leg bones and
then they came back the next weekend
they found a mammoth tusk and they found
these saw bones a few of them we got 15
of them now that they
found and so I told told everybody the
those bones are now called the Spitzer
the Spitzer
findes two little young daughters found
them sometimes it just takes a new set
of eyes I don't know how many of those
we've picked up in the past but we never
looked at it that way so I brought one
with me all right this this is the one
that I carbon
dated and so this is the one that's 200
plus years old right now that see you
see that Notch right there that's what I
cut out to send in to get carbon at and
so this is uh
boy this is uh some sort of a joint is
that a femur is that the top of a femur
uh the lady Janette Rhymes Dakota
Huntress she thinks it's a moose moose
leg bone but set it on its end there
other other
end okay now 200 years ago what kind of
utility would that have to do
that what kind of utility to do that
yeah what do you mean the people that
did that why would they have a a bone
like that I would imagine to get to the
marrow yeah but then what you eat it
maybe a candle maybe some like some
marrow to well I would imagine they're
eating the marrow because people have
always eaten the marrow and that's how
they do it I mean if you get marrow now
that's how you do it but I think there's
some utility to that bone is what I'm
saying yeah just the way it sits
it could have put fire Embers in it to
keep you know overnight cuz this was 200
years ago yeah this was 100 years before
Fairbanks was discovered this was this
is even more of a mystery to me so is
this uh
Russians it's obviously own by Russia
it's about the same time frame yeah
Russians owned Alaska and um you know I
wouldn't surprise me if they didn't go
up they found an Anchorage in the late
1700s I think the utility of it is just
a coincidence honestly because it
doesn't look like it's been worked at
the bottom no no no I I agree with you I
I don't know yeah that's the whole thing
none of us know I mean I'm sure they
have used some of these before like that
for something but uh if I had a guess I
would I would guess that this is just
something that they did to get at the
marrow where all the good fat is you
know maybe they had some vodka they P it
in
there perhaps I don't know they probably
had some kind of metal cups back then
well those two little you just showed uh
they look like cups to me they could
have been they they certainly could be
some sort of a a thing that you could
drink out of certainly the right size
for a good shot of vodka yep but so were
there supposedly people living in that
area back then no
no h h it's right cuz up till now the
dating sequences have been 3,000 be
before present to now is 40,000 years
before present that puts it up to 200
years before present which is
interesting it is
interesting so what what do you think is
going on I have no idea does anybody
have a a theory there's probably a lot
of theories but that's the whole point
about all this stuff nobody knows well
at least we know you didn't come up with
evidence that the saw is older than
5,000 years old which is one of the
things that we were thinking which is I
was hoping that was going to be the case
yeah that would have been Wild and when
he when I got the car carbon dates I'm
going a damn
it but thinking about it though it's
even more of a more of an interesting
thing how much of a recorded history do
we have of that area from 200 years ago
none none so was it mostly like have you
ever seen that uh wner Herzog
documentary uh Happy People life in the
tiger uhuh it's about people who live in
Siberia right now to this day and they
live this in incredibly primitive life
the really all they have is snowmobiles
and some hand tools and um you know
maybe some chainsaws and most of what
they do is just living off the land
trapping fishing hunting that's it Y and
they you know there very low instances
of mental illness everybody's very happy
all these communities of these people
living together just you know surviving
living off the land sub subsistence
lifestyle but I don't think there's much
historical record on those people you
know the people that are alive there
right now if they were to die off 200
years from now what evidence is there of
them other than you might you might find
some stuff that they did you might find
some trees they cut down or some some
logs or whatever is going to be around
still 200 years from now that'll be
preserved yep well we did find that
skinning uh rock across the valley on
top of a hill that still don't know
where that's how old that is or where
that's from skinning Rock skinning Rock
it's posted there and it's uh been
worked so it's yeah there's even a
little indent on the side for your
finger as you flesh something out and
what is it made out of stone from
Eastern Europe remember we talked a
little bit that's right that's right uh
and it wasn't local right so there was a
lot of traveling migrating going on
across that bearing land bridge because
it was Ice free Corridor yeah and it
went all the way into the lower 48
M so there's a lot of stuff that we find
as I said last time that they say didn't
live there but it sure died there yeah
like let's talk about that like what
different animals did they say didn't
live there that you personally in your
company has found evidence of direwolves
being one of
them uh Sabertooth being another one my
I found one and my company found one
before before I was around sent him to
New York City I asked to see him but
they didn't have them
available and let's see what else we got
Badgers elk and they didn't think they
were around back then no why did they
not think that elk were in that area
back then cuz elk are in Alaska because
they they never found any elk bones
right but that's it it's just they
didn't find the bones they didn't find
the bones but they literally didn't
think that saber 2 igles lived in that
area they didn't think that in fact uh
in that film that documentary film film
Pat dren Miller who's the Cur curator
now and the director of the museum says
to their knowledge none of them ever
been found there wow but to my knowledge
they have been because on a shipping
manifest am andh that one was sent to
them ah the one I found was stolen by
the British museum never
returned so I'm on kind of a little bit
of a rampage these days about the
museums and what they're know with these
collections it's it's kind of a one man
onean thing it's a cause I think it's
important well I think it is important
because these museums are run by these
academics and
academics unfortunately some of them
tend to be very arrogant and they they
want to be able to
control whatever narrative they have or
whatever information they have and they
don't want to be open about it no and
the amh is a private institution but the
Smithson is a public entity that's owned
by us so they answered a different set
of rules so Smithsonian has to respond
to a Foya request am andh this what are
you going to do sue us we'll stump break
you what does that mean bend you over a
log and we'll break you oh with money
with money with lawyers with all that
litigation cost why don't we uh [__]
crowdfund something well because I have
another
plan this is plan's going to work okay I
have people in our state legislature
working on this right now there's a
senator named click Bishop who's on the
finance committee he's on the resources
committee's he's uh the majority whip
and he's in making efforts to get the
bones back to
Alaska from the state of Alaska now &h
might be able to take on John Reeves
this don't break me but they can't do it
to the state of
Alaska state of Alaska go Toe to Toe
with them some
[__] now after we get that through
the house and state legislature the
Senate and the house we'll go to the
Congressional
Delegation you've heard what an act of
Congress is don't you you know what that
is
sure am andh give them their goddamn
bones
back and amh is going to see the light
this is a political solution to this not
not lawyers not all that stuff I got
nothing to gain from
this you know I'm just trying to get
them back in Alaska so we have that
thousand piece puzzle to put together
they were supposed to be studied and
researched in the answers to the
extinction event are within the bones
and so you've never been given
any explanation as to why they haven't
done this
research they didn't feel like it they
just didn't feel like it is it because
they don't have the resources or it just
wasn't a priority for them and this was
all done from the the 1940s there's no
reason for them to go back and take that
stuff and reenact the research or begin
the research it's impossible for them to
come up with any scientific research
because they don't have the stratagraph
information they don't even know where
it was found right but I do let's put it
all together boys and then we'll study
it why I just don't understand why they
wouldn't want to do that that seems to
me an incredible opportunity to attain
Enlightenment on an area that's
fascinating yep I mean have have any
academics reached out to you after the
podcast not that I not that I know of
how
not how not I mean me just finding your
Instagram page I was like Jesus Christ
like how is this guy have all these
bones like this is crazy what is this
place this place seems like what an
amazing fortunate find that you guys
have this one spot 2.1 Acres
and probably a whole lot more around
that area that you just haven't
uncovered yet that has this incredible
wealth of Bones it's amazing it's
[__] incredible yep and that's why
that cut bone by the way I noticed you
don't have a a spitzer bone out there in
your lobby what's a spitzer bone that
that's what we call the Spitzer bones oh
yeah you ain't got one of those in your
lobby no I don't I'm G fix that [__]
okay thank you you're
welcome we do have the step bison head
though I saw it out there it looks nice
where it s we're trying to figure out
how to display it I think I'm going to
have a stand built and just have it sit
out there I've got people going oh he
needs to get a Cadillac and mount it on
the hood o well that's not a bad idea as
long as you don't drive it around once I
get a ranch out here I'll do that I'll
put it on the ranch truck there you
go but I think it n that's not good it
needs to be preserved the blue babe
bison was 38,000 years old and that's
you know they could have known each
other back in the day well it looks old
as [__] it is old as [__] yeah what an
amazing amazing spot you have do you
ever stop and just think how insane it
is I do when I have people like Eric
Spitzer and his daughters show up and
they're just the happiness they're just
so gleeful yeah and sometimes I need to
see that to remember that what we're
doing is kind of
worthwhile no it's very worthwhile means
that people enjoy it and they like
seeing it and they like doing it and
they we just haven't figured out a way
to let everybody do it well it just
seems to me that this is an
extraordinary opportunity to gain some
understanding yeah and that's why I
don't understand why uh these
universities or you know someone hasn't
reached out to you and said hey we need
to really have a fullscale investigation
and find out what happened here